Prince Harry's book spare continues to
break records right around the globe by
exposing the royal family as never
before and now a new book pulls the
curtains back even further and exposes
the other side including why a former
aide describes dealing with Harry and
Megan like dealing with teenagers here
it is here courtiers Intrigue ambition
and the Power Players behind the house
of Windsor has a lot of people talking
and in a Canadian television exclusive
we're joined from London by the book's
author Valentine Lowe Valentine welcome
to the morning show
thank you very much thank you for having
me
our pleasure all right Valentine can you
we begin with a bit of a history lesson
first what exactly does a courtier do
a culture is like a chief of staff to
remember the royal family and they do
all sorts of things they very obviously
they write their speeches they advise
them on policy
um they they they're gatekeeper they
control who they get to see they
organize their diary you know what
efficient engagements they carry out and
very importantly they're kind of with
them
a lot of the time every day hours on end
so there it's a very very close
relationship and you know the principal
the member of the royal family really
depends on the private secretary Jeff
mentioned this off the top Prince
Harry's former aide saying that dealing
with Harry and Megan was like dealing
with teenagers how so
I think they were very difficult they
had well they were different two
different ways I mean Harry he's always
had this obsession with with the media
as we we've learned from Reading Despair
and he used to get really cross about
things and they'd have to deal with that
but
um and Megan also she didn't kind of
settle in that well to the royal family
in some ways she did but she had a she
had her own clear ideas about what she
wanted to do and she didn't it's like
she didn't quite get what being a role
was I mean famously as I reveal in the
book when they went on tour to Australia
the first major tour she was going to
rather taken aback by the crowds and
said I can't believe I'm not getting
paid for this
um so she she had a very kind of
different idea of what is to be a role
and they would have rounds I mean
famously when um in the summer of uh
2019
um Harry took four private jets in a
space for a very few days uh and he'd
have stand-up routes with his staff and
and they were just very very difficult
to deal with
um very stubborn
um fixed ideas uh and the coaches tried
to explain to them you know we've got to
deal with the real world the media for
instance is here to stay it's not going
to go away but it was a message that was
falling on deaf ears
now Valentine you also write about Harry
refusing to meet with William at times
claiming he was afraid their
conversations might be leaked to the
Press was that fear was it Justified and
how did they ultimately communicate
well this particular incident uh was
around the time of the documentary about
uh Harry and Megan's tour of Africa when
clearly both of them were in a bad way
and William was reaching out to them and
said listen you know things are not
going right can I come see you and Harry
initially says yeah okay come and see us
uh and then he says well who do you have
to tell and he says well I've got to
tell my private secretary because I've
got to change my diary uh and Williams
sort of Harry says well in that case
don't come because as you say fear of it
being leaked I think Harry
he's got a strange idea he's got a fix a
fixed the fixation that the palace was
leaking bad stuff about him now yes
stories did come out but I I don't
recognize this idea of the palace on a
systematic basis leaking negative
stories for Harry and Megan's just not
my experience and I've spoken to a
fellow Royal correspondence it's not
their experience either
um so
um the meeting never happened it was
tragic it was one possible way in which
those two brothers might have started to
improve their relationship but never
happened
um you know I guess they they continued
to Whatsapp
um which is one of their favorite method
methods of communication but also they
did what members of the royal family
always do they've got this structure
around them they've got these people who
work for them and they use their people
to communicate it's weird you thought
you know in your own personal family
relations if you want to talk to your
brother or your sister or your aunt or
your mum or your granny uh you pick up
the phone and ring them yourself
in the royal family yes that sometimes
happens but also they use their cultures
to communicate
so Valentine are you saying that you
disagree with Prince Harry's comments
about the comms teams who work for
senior members of the royal family that
they work against each other for their
principle
I mean it's certainly true that
different households can battle against
each other can jockey for position uh
try and get the best
media the best uh Dar engagements for
their principle but the the idea that
um the different households were
briefing against Harry I don't recognize
that now of course it did happen quite
badly in the days of Charles and Diana
when that marriage was was going south
uh but I think even then it wasn't so
much the actual households believing uh
against each other as people just
outside the household that was the main
culprit although it it also happened
within the household there were there
was um particularly around the time of
um when Camilla was being rehabilitated
uh there was someone who used to do a
lot of in a very energetic briefing
there but I don't recognize it uh in the
Harry and William era I mean William was
very careful very kind of puncture is he
didn't want to stir up
um ill feelings in the family it's not
the way William operates uh so it's this
is not a picture I recognize
and welcome back to TMS and our Canadian
television exclusive with a valentine
Lowe author of courtiers intrigue
ambition and the Power Players behind
the house of Windsor Valentine we've
heard a lot about Angela Kelly a
courtier who worked for the late Queen
she was her closest aide in his Memoir
Harry labeled her as a troublemaker can
you tell us more about her and why Harry
gave her that label
um he gave her that label because I
think she was a match for him she
wouldn't take any nonsense from him
um and their most significant uh Contra
top was over the Tiara that Megan was
going to wear for the wedding
and they had a the ra wasn't over which
Tiara to wear that was all sorted out uh
earlier um they had a meeting with the
queen Megan tried on a few Tiaras chose
one that was all lovely the problem was
trying it on because you can imagine
you're gonna wear a tiara you've got to
have your hair right so the appointment
was made with Megan's hairdresser and
then she wanted that to have the Tiara
so she said the hairdresser could you
know know what to do with her hair but
the problem was she hadn't fixed up with
Angela Kelly and Angela Kelly is the
woman with the key she's in charge of
all the jewelry she's very close to the
queen and she's not a woman to be
messing around with she's she comes from
a working class background her father
was a a crane driver in the Liverpool
docks uh and she's she's a tough one
Angela her nickname is AK-47
um
and uh the day that Megan's hairdresser
turned up from Paris I believe
um they said well we're on the Tiara now
and no one had told Angela Kelly this
and said well I'm not here and if I'm
not here you can't have the Tiara and
Harry was absolutely Furious apparently
he used some pretty some pretty Choice
language uh either at Angela Kelly or
about her and uh Angela Kelly I think it
might have heard such language before
but anyway she wasn't impressed that you
know one understands that the queen had
to have a word with Harry afterwards
all right let's move from The Tiara to
the Dress next if we could Valentine
because another tension during the
wedding preparations of course was this
now much talked about dispute between
Megan and Princess Catherine regarding
Charlotte's ill-fitting wedding dress
what more can you tell us about that
well this is this is very hard to get to
the Baltimore
um you know the original version we all
heard was that uh Megan had made Kate
cry
and then Harry says a version that you
know it was K so it was Megan who cried
he came back and found Megan on the
floor crying you know some instant
incredibly trivial about you know me
altering the bridesmaids dresses so they
would actually fit
um and what I do know is that uh after
this round between the two of them Kate
Went rounds Nottingham Cottage to Megan
with a bouquet of flowers uh as a peace
gesture whether it was to say sorry or
just to try and you know make everything
nice and certainly according to one of
my sources Megan shut the door in her
face
hmm all right that's a little nugget I
hadn't heard of yes I also want to ask
you Valentine that about the idea AIDS
believe that Megan and Harry's exit from
the palace was premeditated and that she
wanted to be rejected by the royal
family can you elaborate
yes certainly um
when she first arrived According to some
people her behavior was such she was
she was talking about rejection thinking
about rejection right from the start in
the very very early days shortly after
her existence became known to all of us
um they they didn't like all the
intrusion from the journalists um Harry
was desperate for them for the his press
guy to put out a statement uh
criticizing all the media had been sort
of camped outside Megan's flat in
Toronto and so forth
um and uh he was worried that uh Megan
was going to dump him unless he did this
and very significantly uh Megan uh said
to one of the senior people uh in Harris
team
I know how this works you don't care
about the girlfriend she so rejection
was on her mind straight from right
right from the start but it's it you
shouldn't think about it in terms of
merely Megan wanting rejection and you
know plotting a way out which is
certainly what some people believe
because you're going to realize that
Harry was deeply unhappy he he he didn't
like his position the royal family he
didn't like dealing with the media he
had a sense of frustration about trying
to do some good in the world and felt
the the senior courties of the palace
for holding him back all that fed on a
sort of and and led to the sense of uh
frustration on his part uh and and
dissatisfaction
um and someone said to me someone very
senior who knew Harry well they said to
me
in a funny way and this is the person
who just disapproves what those two did
he said in a funny way actually she
didn't he she did him the greatest
kindness because we knew he was on we
would we knew that he was unhappy but we
didn't know what to do about it and she
showed him the way out and I think
that's a very interesting way of looking
at it
you mentioned Camilla a little earlier
now Harry has long been critical of
Queen consort Camilla especially in the
new book is this criticism valid and do
you think it's now a line that's being
crossed for King Charles
Charles will absolutely be upset about
that he he he he loves Camilla very much
he hates to see any criticism of her and
he will take it very badly I think uh
that Harry should have said these things
um and Harry's also kind of wrong in one
respect uh he effectively accuses
Camilla leaking the contents of her
first conversation with William whereas
in fact it's well known that the person
responsible for that was um Camilla's
private secretary a woman called Amanda
McManus who leaked it by accident she
happened to say something to her husband
who happened to say something to someone
else and it ended up reaching the Sun
newspaper but it wasn't a deliberate
leak so Harry's being very unfair to her
on the other hand it has to be uh
accepted that
Camilla did have working for her uh a
Communications guy who was quite Adept
from the Dark Arts of of leaking and
planting stories so you know she may not
be entirely blameless
all right so having said all of that and
taking all of this into account
Valentine do you believe that there is
reconciliation possible can the royal
family come together and if so do you
think it might happen in time for the
king's coronation in May
I think it's going to be incredibly
difficult wouldn't like to rule this out
because I'm an eternal optimist but if
you think about it one of the Royal
Family's main complaints now is that
they can't have a private conversation
with Harry without it hitting the media
in some form eventually
um and how if you have reconciliation
how do you do it you have to have very
difficult private
conversations where both sides you know
give some ground and and I don't really
see how you have those conversations if
one side doesn't trust the other to leak
it or not leak it to it just put it
there in the next book or television
program so
um the ground rules for those
conversations are going to be very
difficult let's hope they can happen
because you know one doesn't like to see
a family tear itself apart
because the rules have changed that is
for sure
as we always say here on the show we are
just scratching the surface when it
comes to Revelations and story lines
it's called courtiers Intrigue ambition
and the Power Players behind the house
of Windsor it'll be released on January
24th Valentine thank you so much for
joining us
thank you